la mort de grégory un enfant de 5 ans
une péritonite que les médecins
n'avaient pas diagnostiquer ses parents
portent plainte violents affrontements à
bastia en corse le gouvernement propose
la reprise des négociations sur de
nouvelles bases
la rencontre mitterrand arafat elle aura
bien lieu ce sens en france l'elysée l'a
confirmé la date n'est pas dans fortis
invité de ce journal valéry giscard
d'estaing l'ancien président analysera
les résultats des élections en union
soviétique
la pollution en alaska la responsabilité
du commandant qui semble-t-il avait vu
mais aussi la faillite des secours
bonsoir et tout d'abord cette affaire
tragique la mort d'un enfant de 5 ans
par erreur de diagnostic des médecins
nous sommes à noël dernier grégory
souffre du ventre sa mère l'emmène chez
1 puis chez plusieurs médecins
aucun d'entre eux n'est capable de
diagnostiquer une péritonite
et il le renvoie chez lui le 11 janvier
grégory meurent aujourd'hui
la justice est saisie isabelle stress à
la bouse pendant 18 jours grégory et sa
mère ont erré de médecin en médecin de
service de pédiatrie en service
d'urgence 18 jours d'incertitude
personne n'a décelé que grégory pouvait
mourir le 23 décembre dernier l'enfant
se plaint de maux de ventre sa mère
appelle un médecin de nuit qui conseille
un examen radiologique à l'hôpital
sainte camille de bry-sur-marne de
diagnostic différent sont établis en
deux jours début d'aphasie site puis
d'occlusion intestinale à chaque fois
grégory renvoyé chez lui avec un
traitement d'autres médecins sont
consultés leurs conclusions sont
toujours rassurant j'ai vu en toi
dix sept docteurs en tout entre les
médecins de nuit il est médecin à
l'hôpital
à aucun moment il en laisse apparaître
un jeune homme non non rien du tout le
pas et c'était moi qui me faisais des
l'idée est que on est arrivé à une
époque on écoutait trop les enfants
rient fidèles mais finalement comme je
devais passer toute la journée sur lui
mon dû écouter faudrait peut-être le
laisser un petit peu s'amuser tout seul
et tout parce qu'ils voient vous êtes
crispé autour de lui alors le 7 janvier
grégory est toujours malade sa mère
l'emmène à l'hôpital de montfermeil
encore un nouveau diagnostic une gastro
entérite
quatre jours plus tard l'enfant meurt
chez lui des suites d'une péritonite ap
andy cullers
il ya une erreur de diagnostic cette
erreur
était sans doute commises par de
nombreux médecins puisque cet enfant
était dû à de multiples reprises mais il
est certain que le dernier examen fait à
montfermeil a été sans doute décisif
dans l'issue de ce qui s'est passé
alors quand le diagnostic n'est pas
évident est ce qu'il vaut pas mieux
pêcher par excès de prudence
je pense qu'il aurait été plus
raisonnable de garder cet enfant
la justice est saisie de cette affaire
les parents de grégory ont porté plainte
une information judiciaire contre x a
été ouverte pour homicide involontaire
voilà donc pour les faits avec nous en
duplex de l'hôpital trousseau à paris le
professeur l'as far qui est chef de
service de pédiatrie
bonsoir monsieur quel sentiment vous
inspire une affaire de ce genre
tout d'abord je voudrais dire aux
parents que je comprends leur peine et
que je comprends aussi qu'il y ait du
mal à comprendre ce qui s'est passé
j'imagine bien alors revenons un peu sur
une affaire de ce genre pas fortement
tels là mais quand des médecins ont un
doute
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qu'ils
doivent faire mais d'abord je crois que
c'est pas les médecins et en particulier
les pédiatres qui sont habitués à parler
écouter les maires doivent leur faire
confiance
il n'y a pas de médecine sans de
confiance et la première confiance du
médecin c'est d'écouter et de croire ce
que disent les parents il est certain
que parfois l'anxiété des mers modifie
le leur dire est que le médecin doit
s'efforcer de trouver des signes
objectifs
aux dires des parents dans une affaire
comme celle là je crois que le point
important c'était de rechercher des
signes objectifs qui pouvait orienter le
diagnostic et éventuellement prendre
consultation d'autres médecins qui
étaient autour de lui d'aucun de ses
médecins mais je crois que le problème
de la consultation si j'ai bien compris
l'histoire dans cette affaire-là de ne
s'est pas posée dans la mesure où de
nombreux médecins ont examiné cet enfant
je crois qu'il faut trouver s'éprennent
de la compétence
je crois qu'il ne s'agit pas de
multiplier médecins il faut avoir des
médecins qui sont compétents mais alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire aux parents
parce que en fait les parents sont très
angoissés dans une situation comme ça et
qu'est ce que peuvent faire quand ils
sont confrontés à une situation d'une
telle nature
je crois d'abord que
dans l'ensemble les urgences en
particulier à paris dans les grandes
villes de france se passe bien si je
prends l'exemple par exemple de
l'hôpital trousseau
une centaine d'enfants sont examinés
chaque nuit et les cas que tel que celui
qu'on eut rapporté sont tout à fait
exceptionnelles et statistiquement le
nombre de ses erreurs a sûrement
diminuer considérablement
avec les progrès de la biologie et de la
radiologie ne reste pas moins vrai que
chaque erreur médicale est intolérable
et qu' elle pose deux problèmes de nos
systèmes de sécurité de nos systèmes
d'examen de nos systèmes de garde et le
cas du petit grégory repose bien
évidemment ce problème puisque cet
enfant est examinée dans deux
excellentes hôpitaux dans des services
tout à fait compétent est ce que ça veut
dire simplement que la médecine n'est
pas infaillible
la médecine est sûrement pas infaillible
ou plutôt les médecins ne sont pas
infaillibles
nous devons cependant en permanence
remettre en cause nous appris et nous
devons savoir qu en douter et dans le
cas particulier peut-être que les
médecins n'ont pas assez douter de leur
diagnostic
merci professeur lasfargue j'ajoute
enfin toujours dans ce même domaine de
la médecine ce décès suspect dans une
clinique dans le lot-et-garonne là
encore une enquête judiciaire a été
ouverte une patiente est morte après une
intervention gynécologique bening dans
une clinique de villeneuve sur lot
une enquête judiciaire est ouverte la
corse avec d'abord cette proposition du
gouvernement l'hôtel matignon a annoncé
qu'il proposait la reprise des
négociations sur de nouvelles bases les
discussions sont menées seront menée
cette fois par le ministre de la
fonction publique michel durafour en
personne c'est une concession du
gouvernement
mais sur place aujourd'hui le bras de
fer a continué ainsi à bastia il ya eu
de très violents affrontements
françoise joly un rituel
il est 15 heures les crs sont retranchés
dans la préfecture des manifestants leur
jettent des pierres la riposte des
forces de l'ordre est presque immédiate
tirs de grenades lacrymogènes et charge
pour tenter de disperser les
manifestants
d'heure en heure les échanges sont de
plus en plus violent c'est un véritable
combat de rue qui s'engagent mais sans
affrontements physiques
cette fois ci en première ligne les
syndicalistes qui ne contiennent plus
les manifs essence ils sont 3 400 façade
200 crs et gardes mobiles ans et moi
même toujours des affrontements
au moins trois personnes ont été
blessées par ge de manifestants ainsi
que six crs nos forces de l'ordre qui
ont dû se replier sur la préfecture puis
le face à face continue oui ce soir
depuis une demi heure à peu près le
calme semble revenu à bastia mais
aujourd'hui en effet la corse à renouer
partiellement en tout cas avec le blocus
aussi trafic aérien très pertubé trafic
maritime bloqués
ajaccio il ya eu aussi des
rassemblements nicolas jacobs ajaccio
avec son inséparable drapeau dans le sac
à dos catherine chance elle est de
toutes les manifestations de tous les
rassemblements depuis cinq semaines et
ce matin il était toujours aussi décidé
on ne se mélange pas et à quelques
mètres de la toussaint barbolosi membres
de l'union patronale rejoint lui un
autre rassemblement celui des chefs
d'entreprises et artisans 2000 les
représentants de la quasi totalité des
chefs d'entreprises et artisans de l'île
ont ainsi décidé de suspendre tout
paiement des charges sociales et taxes
ils manifesteront samedi et demande même
la démission de l'assemblée régionale
cohorte et tout cela clame qu'il ne va
pas à l'encontre des grévistes
au contraire si ce mois ci les
fonctionnaires ne seront pas payer les
retraités n'auront pas leur pension au
total 170 millions d'oeufs en
irrigueront pas l'économie les feuilles
d'impôts que les manifestants ont brûlé
ce matin nous changerons rien d'ailleurs
elle était vierge
le chômage a diminué en février le
chiffre publié par le ministère du
travail fait état d'une baisse de 0,8
pour cent en février donc en données
corrigées des variations saisonnières en
janvier dernier la baisse avait état et
avait déjà été de 0,6 pour cent 5
février il y avait donc deux millions
sept cent vingt-sept mille 300
demandeurs d'emploi 20600 chômeurs en
moins cet après midi dernière table
ronde dans le domaine de l'éducation le
ministre et les syndicats se retrouver
pour parler de la revalorisation du
métier d'enseignant
au total près de 18 milliards de francs
ils seront consacrés à cette
revalorisation au cours des dix
prochaines années c'est ce qu'a annoncé
lionel jospin mais les syndicats ne sont
toujours pas d'accord
chantal kimmerlin
il y à des avancées mais c'est un peu
juste selon la formule d'un syndicaliste
il y à des avancées puisque au budget
initial de 11 milliards pour la
revalorisation lionel jospin donne un
petit coup de pouce de 600 millions de
francs
le plan de revalorisation est également
prolonger de quatre ans jusqu'en 98 au
total 18 milliards sur 10 ans pour
améliorer le salaire des enseignants
pour les instituteurs 200 francs de plus
par mois des 70 90 et les élèves
instituteurs 400 francs de plus ceux qui
choisiront d'aller dans des zones
d'éducation plus difficile recevront une
prime annuelle de 12 mille francs les
nouveaux instituteurs engagé avec une
licence gagneront mille francs de plus
par mois
d92 les professeurs de collèges et de
lycées gagneront minimum 500 francs de
plus par mois et une prime annuelle de
6000 francs pour les conseils de classes
toutes les carrières seront accélérées
et améliorées
ce n'est pas assez estime ce soir les
syndicats qui se sont refusés à signer
un accord savais que nous avions des
revendications très simple des
augmentations de salaire en point
d'indicé vernement a choisi des voies
très compliqué dans un dispositif qu'il
est important de savoir mettre en oeuvre
et la mise en oeuvre la mise en musique
peut varier
nous sommes donc ici aussi pour exercer
une pression assez du sur la façon dont
le dispositif va être mise en oeuvre
signeront signerons pas lionel jospin
pour sa part reste serein le
gouvernement mettra en oeuvre ces
mesures de revalorisation précise-t-il
avec ou sans l'accord des syndicats
l'inculpation de roland nungesser le
maire de nogent sur marne a été inculpé
de corruption recel d'abus de biens
sociaux et recel de faux en écriture il
s'agit de la sphère des pots-de-vin et
des fausses factures du sud est monsieur
nungesser qui a toujours nié et la 18e
personne à être inculpée dans cette
affaire la rencontre mitterrand arafat
c'est officiel elle aura lieu en france
le porte parole de l'elysée l'annoncé en
effet tout à l'heure il a annoncé que le
président mitterrand rencontrerait le
leader de l'ol paie en france la date
n'est pas encore fixée mais ce sera sans
doute en 89 comme l'avait laissé
entendre le chef de l'état auparavant
une rencontre qui
une rencontre en france donc qui pose
bien sûr un certain nombre de problèmes
jérôme baugnies 17 décembre dernier au
sommet franco-africain de casablanca le
président mitterrand annonce pour la
première fois être prêt à rencontrer
yasser arafat chef de l'organisation de
libération de la palestine l'obstacle
majeur à une telle rencontre avait été
levé un mois auparavant à alger quand la
centrale palestinienne tout en
proclamant la création de la palestine
avait enfin accepté à la demande de
l'onu
le principe de la reconnaissance de
l'état d'israël depuis le chef de l'olp
et a effectué un sans faute diplomatique
à strasbourg au parlement européen le 7
décembre
invité par le groupe socialiste à madrid
au début de l'année avec roland dumas
ministre des affaires étrangères
aujourd'hui le communiqué de l'elysée
met fin aux spéculations sur le lieu de
la rencontre au sommet france au lp on
avait parlé du caire de tunis ou même
d'alger c'est à paris que françois
mitterrand rencontrera yasser arafat à
une date fixée par le président de la
république et shamir le premier ministre
israélien avait fait part à l'elysée de
ces extrêmes réserves et la décision
d'aujourd'hui ne peut que provoquer des
remous à tel-aviv mais aussi dans la
communauté juive française les élections
d'union soviétique qui a réellement
gagné ces élections c'est toute la
question
gorbatchev ou les réformateurs celui qui
a amené la pérestroïka ou ceux qui
ensuite ont bénéficié de cette ouverture
il faut tenter maintenant de tirer les
conclusions de ce scrutin mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que l'échec de nombreux
responsables du parti communiste à semer
un grand désarroi dans les milieux
politique soviétique
jacques maire lido
bureaucratie couler c'est peut être
ainsi que l'on pourrait résumer les
votes de ses 184 millions d'électeurs
soviétique qui devait désigner les 1500
élus du congrès des députés du peuple
la victoire la plus célèbre est bien sûr
celle de boris elstine à moscou un
communiste rebelles libéral qui a fait
la nique à l'appareil du parti
mais ce raz de marée contestataires ne
se limite pas à la capitale soviétique
c'est ainsi que les mouvements
nationalistes en porte une très large
victoire dans les pays baltes en
lettonie estonie lituanie déroute encore
des apparatchiks en ukraine dans le nord
du caucase et au kazakhstan où le
premier secrétaire du parti a été battu
par un jeune entrepreneur
ce ne sont là encore que des résultats
partiels
il faudra attendre une dizaine de jours
pour être en possession des résultats
complets mais on en sait suffisamment
aujourd'hui pour que la presse
soviétique ce temps complet désarroi la
thèse officielle est que ce sont la
glace nas et la pérestroïka contre ils
ont fait de ces élections mais il faut
tout de même reconnaître un chiffre
environ 20% des membres du parti
communiste ont été battus alors avec
nous un observateur privilégié de ces
problèmes c'est valéry giscard d'estaing
monsieur le président vous êtes le
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de l'assemblée puis vous
connaissez bien l'union soviétique vous
étiez encore au mois de janvier dernier
alors première question est ce que vous
n'avez pas le sentiment comme je le
disais en titre tout à leur commencement
que le second parc chef un peu joué les
apprentis sorciers
je ne crois pas il faut se rappeler ce
qui s'est passé d'abord c'est la
première fois que les soviétiques
votaient que les russes
votre terre c'était la troisième fois
depuis le début du siècle
nous nous sommes habitués à voir des
élections tout le temps les élections
c'est pour nous balade mais pour eux ils
ont voté en 1906 ils ont voté en 1917 et
ils ont voté en 1989 et cette feuille
est une vraie campagne il ya eu une
vraie campagne vous savez qu'il ya eu
des endroits où derrick un seul candidat
n'est pas c'est une campagne qui ne
ressemble pas encore au nôtre il faut
pas se tromper
donc dans certains endroits vous n'aviez
qu'un seul candidat mais dans les trois
quarts des endroits vous aviez plusieurs
candidats de deux à douze et ils ont
fait les vrais cantal à la fois la terre
d'union soviétique à l'extérieur lui
apportèrent par exemple un journal tout
brand elle de madère america belle il y
avait un interview de eltsine qui vient
sa campagne dans la presse américaine la
semaine dernière donc une vraie campagne
est d'ailleurs ce qu'ils veulent frapper
à moscou en janvier c'est que tout le
monde voulait être candidat
les académiciens les les hauts
fonctionnaires les écrivains ainsi de
suite
donc ils ont voté y ait une vraie
élection il devrait camper dès lors les
enseignements d'abord il ya une question
que nous posions toujours je me souviens
c'était la question suivante on se
disait si dans un pays communiste les
gens pouvaient voter
comment votre équipe et j'ai souvent
posé cette question à nos ambassadeurs
aux experts internationaux et la réponse
qui me faisaient était de dire écoutez
c'est difficile à savoir mais notre
évaluation c'est qu'au fond il y aura à
peu près 15 % de gens qu'ils voteraient
pour le régime
est-ce que son str est frappant dans
cette élection soviétique c'est qu'on
retrouve une proportion de ce genre par
exemple la mostra en examen sous et à
leningrad et démocrates qui est une
ville je dirais de tradition plus
conservatrice aux produits du communisme
la même chose à l'ouvrier les deux
chantiers navals bas le chef du parti
dans une proportion de ce type justement
lorsque une vérité révélée comme ça ne
va pas entraîner des conséquences
beaucoup plus importante qui sort
gagnant finalement de ces élections le
changement je crois que c'est ce qui est
relatif à se rappeler que gorbatchev
avait pris un risque énorme
ça remonte au 28 juin dernier y annoncer
devant l'assemblée parti qu'il y aurait
des élections
ces élections elles au mois de mars
elles ont eu lieu et qu'il aurait le
la multiplicité de candidatures
plusieurs candidatures possibles celle
en flic a pris le risque
alors ce qui est frappant c'est que les
électeurs ont répondu nous voulons
davantage de pétrole parce que vous
pourriez le faire la remarque suivante
en disant mais après tout gambadent sur
fait le premier secrétaire du parti
communiste
donc lorsque les candidats communistes
normalement ceux qui veulent voter
pendant ma chance devrait voter pour les
candidats du parti
mais les soviétiques ont vu que le parti
frehner parce que entre le moment les
élections commencer et puis le vote de
dimanche
la machine du parti à jouer vous savez
par exemple que le parti désigne des
candidats il désigne son député sur le
total de 2500 le parti l'a désigné que
un candidat dans chaque cas donc il y en
eut que le parti freinet ce qui fait que
les électeurs lorsqu'ils ont une
chouette candidat officiel du parti et
un candidat sans gazon sur les réformes
ils ont voté pour de l'effort alors vous
disiez que c'est le changement qui est
vainqueur mais ce que michael gorbatchev
je reviens à ma question et j'insiste
est-ce que mikhaïl gorbatchev maîtres de
ce changement donc d'abord soit notons
ça si vous voulez les gens demandaient
plus de pétrole cas où d'aller plus vite
dans la pérestroïka et qu'elle est
l'obstacle sur lequel le but
l'évolution en union soviétique c'est
l'obstacle économique et social parce
qu'au fond à l'heure actuelle lien
progrès politique visible il n'y a pas
de progrès y est même proche un recul
sur le plan économique et sociale cds
les conditions de vie des soviétiques et
jusqu'à présent dans ma soeur fait assez
prudent il ya quelques jours il ya eu
une réunion sur l'agriculture
je pense que vous en avez rendu compte
dans votre journal et ils ont pris des
décisions très prudente
alors qu'il avait annoncé qu'on allait
louer très largement des terres aux
agriculteurs à paris ce thème de baux à
long terme qui ressemble à notre statut
du fermage en réalité ils sont revenus
en arrière c'était à qui donner on va
faire ça à l'intérieur du système des
kolkhozes et des sovkhozes et donc on
enferme ensemble à monsieur présent les
démocraties occidentales n'ont pas un
rôle à jouer en aidant peut être
économiquement monsieur gorbatchev
justement alors je pense si blake le
grand problème qu'on va voir revenir 22
l'été prochain ça va être le problème
économique et social avec un problème
épouvantable qu'est le problème de la
réforme des prix puisque c'est un
problème qui naturellement soulèvera des
réactions d'impopularité il faut
augmenter les prix
consommation ont augmenté les prix du
chauffage ont augmenté les prix des
carburants et cetera donc je pense qu'il
faut qu'il ya des satisfactions donner
en même temps à la population soviétique
et il faut donc une politique globale
je pense que dans cette politique
globale l'occident peut apporter un
concours l'évolution du dossier
alors justement un freinage élargir un
petit peu le problème parce qu'on voit
que la pérestroïka est une contagion sur
les dix autres pays les démocraties
d'auxerre démocraties populaires pardon
est-ce que l' équilibre entre l'europe
de l'ouest et l'europe de l'est ce ne
risque pas d'en être affectée si nous ne
devons pas souhaité laventure je dis
franchement nous avons connue et
l'avenir at on appris du drame en
hongrie en creux de vague en pologne où
j'ai connu la table alors que j'étais
président dans les années dans l'année
80 nous ne devons pas souhaité des
drames et une évolution en cours
nous devons tout faire pour cette
évolution se poursuivent d'agrément
qu'elles sont ici pour nous les
européens de l'ouest pour nos quoi nous
sommes habitués à vivre au fond nous
avons connu à l'est union soviétique
menaçante mais une situation qui était
immobile et maintenant dans une
situation dans laquelle une seule est
écrite - menaçante mais une situation
qui bouge est dans une situation qui
bouge il faut pouvoir s'adapter il faut
pouvoir prendre des initiatives pour
répondre à des situations qui peuvent
devenir imprévues alors d'abord je crois
qu'il faut que cette fois l'europe qu'il
fasse je vous laisse je trouve tout à
fait vous fait pas du tout une politique
allemande pour la hongrie les puits
française pour la pologne
il faut nous ayons la même même si
certains nous a naturellement des
intérêts plus précis dans tel ou tel
pays
donc il faut qu'il y ait une politique
commune de l'europe et puis faut qu'ils
aient une attitude pour les pays qui
vis-à-vis des pays sont entre l'union
soviétique et nous et certains ces pays
souhaitent rester proche de l'union
soviétique sont doux et certains autres
visiblement envie de se rapprocher du
modèle de l'europe oxyde d asnières
question suffit sinon on parle point de
l'europe le 18 juin star rendez vous
important pour l'europe
on connaît votre position vous êtes pour
l'union pour une seule liste rpr udf
est ce que le seul message de l'union
est ce que c'est suffisant pour
l'opposition et s'il ya deux listes
quelle sera votre position
est ce que vous serez tous le même
candidat ou pas d'abord juste
rose pour relier votre question ce que
nous venons de dire il faut voir que la
sphère de l'europe c'est très important
bien sûr c'est pour ça que c'est très
important et mon opinion elle est lassée
des élections on l'a vu dans certaines
directions - d'ailleurs dans les
élections municipales
mais là c'est très important c'est à
dire que le sort de notre façon de vivre
on le sort de nos enfants est
probablement plus déterminés par ce qui
se passera en europe que par toutes nos
nos propres décisions
donc est très important moi je souhaite
une élection européenne
je ne souhaite pas une élection
politicienne se souhaitent une élection
européenne où les françaises et les
français de toutes conditions activités
diront ce qu'ils pensent et ce qu'ils
veulent pour l'europe
je souhaite que dans cette élection
européenne l'opposition se présente avec
la liste la plus large possible
c'est à dire comprenant toute
l'opposition parlementaire et qu'elles
se présentent sur des objectifs
européens pas sur les objectifs
politiciens mais sur des objectifs
européens et je souhaite que cette liste
puisque elle représentera la france vise
élites extérieures au cours des cinq
prochaines années face une large place
au renouvellement savez qu'il ya une
menace d'une autre liste même au sein du
oui mais ça saoule et jouent pas en
parler aujourd'hui nous sommes
d'ailleurs vous sentez bien que sommes
pas dans ce débat là je vous dis ce que
je souhaite parce que je crois que une
liste commune à toute l'opposition avec
des objectifs communs sur l'europe
c'est ce qui est dans l'intérêt de
l'europe et c'est ce qui est dans
l'intérêt de la france
merci monsieur le président merci
beaucoup la suite de l'actualité
maintenant avec la yougoslavie et plus
précisément les manifestations
meurtrières au kosovo le kosovo c'est
l'une des provinces de la yougoslavie
elle est en principe autonome mais elle
veut encore plus d'autonomie
cette fois le sang a coulé plus de 20
morts au cours d'affrontements entre
manifestants d'origine albanaise et
forces de l'ordre
michel mompontet rappelle l'enchaînement
récent de ces violences
ce matin au sein du parlement hugo slave
à belgrade
ouverture de séance très solennel pour
un vote historique 23 amendements
adoptés à l'unanimité et qui redonne
constitutionnellement à la serbie les
droits les prérogatives mais aussi les
pouvoirs qu'elle réclame et sur sa
province voisine le kosovo un kosovo
musulmans farouchement hostile à ses
voisins serbes et qui depuis quinze ans
vivait une quasi autonomie de fées
accordée par quito une quasi autonomie
est aujourd'hui interrompue
la serbie a repris sa tutelle dans les
rues de pristina
la réaction des albanais de souche ne
s'est pas fait attendre
ici on se sent bien sur coup musulmans
que slave et ce retour à la dépendance
est inacceptable et la violence des
affrontements d'aujourd'hui a dépassé
les prévisions les plus pessimistes
un véritable climat de guerre civile
d'insurrection en réponse au vote du
parlement
l'état de siège et la très nombreuse de
présence policière sur place n'ont pu
empêcher ces affrontements les plus
graves dans ce pays depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale
le fantôme de l'éclatement de la
yougoslavie
voilà bien le véritable enjeu qui se
joue actuellement dans les rues de
pristina la capitale du kosovo
voyons maintenant d'autres informations
internationales importantes de cette
journée est tout d'abord la révolte dans
un pénitencier au guatemala des mutins
retiennent toujours 600 personnes en
otages éric perrin poursuite des
négociations avec les mutins du
pénitencier de pavone au guatemala qui
retiennent en otages depuis dimanche
plus de 600 personnes gardien des
visiteurs
les affrontements entre détenus et
militaires qui encerclent la prison
aurait fait au moins neuf morts
mais après la décision cet après-midi du
gouvernement d'accéder partiellement aux
requêtes des mutins la tension semble
être quelque peu pour bombay
l'organisation indépendantiste basque
eta prolonge sa trêve de la lutte armée
jusqu'au 24 juin
cette décision fait suite aux
négociations alger entre le gouvernement
espagnol et les représentants de l' eta
ces derniers demandent la participation
à cette table ronde de trois dirigeants
basse emprisonné actuellement en france
parmi lesquels yushu tel n'est la numéro
1 de letea militaire la justice
française fait savoir qu'elle n'a reçu
pour le moment aucune demande de la part
des autorités espagnoles
l'airbus a330 volera sous les couleurs
de tbw à la compagnie américaine vient
en effet de passer commande de 40
appareils 20 fermes 20 avec option au
consortium européen airbus industries
confirme ainsi son implantation sur le
continent américain
la marée noire en alaska une catastrophe
extrêmement préoccupante c'est ce qu'a
dit george bush le président américain
tout à l'heure on commence mieux
maintenant à connaître les causes de
l'accident de ce pétrolier mais les
américains semblent toujours aussi
démuni pour faire face à cette pollution
hervé brusini 115 kilomètres-heure parce
que la tempête
c'est le nouvel adversaire de la journée
les opérations de nettoyage ans ont
considérablement ralenti la nappe de
pétrole progresse comme une autoroute
affirment des témoins une autoroute
large comme deux fois la surface de
paris
le désastre est bien là le hareng la
morue le saumon tous sont menacées de
disparition pour de longues années
déplorent les pêcheurs il y en a au
moins pour 15 ans lui celui-ci désastre
écologique économique aussi port de
valdez est fermée les cours du pétrole
augmentent
francky à rossi le président d'exxon
shipping company le propriétaire du
bateau ne peut que plaider coupable nous
sommes mis dans de beaux draps at il
confié une compagnie néerlandaise a été
alerté pour tenter de remettre à flot
l'exxon valdez
josef fritzl où le capitaine du bateau
est en ce moment même interrogé par
quatre enquêteurs fédéraux par trois
fois son permis de conduire automobile
eut été retiré pour être livré ce soir
de l'accident il n'était pas sur le pot
c'est le lieutenant segaud qui dirigeait
la manoeuvre dans cette zone dangereuse
ce lieutenant n'était pas qualifié pour
conduire l'opération accusent la
compagnie exxon comme si déjà elle se
préoccuper du futur procès avant même
que le bateau ne soit renfloué
il s'appelle philippe delaire et il a
joué la fille du même nom ce n'est pas
la première fois d'ailleurs cet homme a
réussi déjà plusieurs cavale avec un
complice il vient de s'évader d'une
maison d'arrêt de l'allier là où
l'histoire devient beaucoup moins drôle
c'est qu'ils ont déjà pris deux
personnes en otage
dominique verdeilhan évasion en plein
jour et devant témoins en plein milieu
de leur promenade dominicale philippe
delaire et alain la cote escaladent le
mur d'enceinte de la prison d'yzeure
dans l'allier
les deux hommes se dirigent vers la
route nationale 7 menaçant d'un couteau
les deux occupants d'une r5 les deux
fuyards prennent leur place dans le
véhicule ce matin les deux hommes font
de l'auto stop
ils prennent une première conductrice en
otage à la sortie de montluçon elle
parcourt plus de 30 km sous la menace
d'un poignard peu avant montaigu sur ce
parking les deux hommes abandonnent la
femme à bord de sa ford taunus après
quoi les deux hommes se dirigent vers un
couple en train de pique-niquer
probablement des touristes la femme
s'exprimerait en anglais
les quatre personnes n'ont à bord d'un
véhicule de couleur gris métallisé
immatriculée à l'étranger
c'est ici que l'on perd la trace des
fuyards des barrages de police sont
immédiatement mis en place dans la
région de riom sans résultat ils sont
levés à 16h30 ce soir les gendarmes
passent au peigne fin tous ceux qui
pourraient être plantes pour la nuit les
deux fugitifs sont considérés comme des
hommes dangereux tous deux étaient en
détention provisoire à la prison
d'yzeure dans l'allier
d'où ils se sont évadés dimanche
après-midi ils sont poursuivis pour
attac et vols à main armée
l'un d'entre eux philippe delaire déjà
condamné est un récidiviste de l'évasion
ce soir les gendarmes ont renouvelé leur
appel à la vigilance
voilà fin du journal tout de suite
sophie davant pour la météo aussi belle
que sa météo de demain dernier journal
ce sera 23h25 un des saignées aussitôt
après star à la barre présenté par
daniel bilalian
bonsoir à demain 20 heures
à